and no welcome to this video okay
goodbye my mouth set up was a little bit
of grand master fader recall is that
from your egopay response are ok let's
see from Argentina yeah I've got going
for benoni ok we can a bank Oh after all
so let's see what happens the other
tremendously high rating at 2,600 on the
pool is really a lot so we're probably
going to get the main line rule which
after ninety three castles efore queen
85 no he goes for a seven-year that's
also possible move now is six young
taking their that's not seen all that
often I think even d takes sometimes as
an option but I go for the normal move
okay yeah i'm currently i'm not quite
sure when this video is released i
wanted to say i'm currently working on a
bank or repertoire it might be already
out by the time this video is actually
on my channel so let's see bishop here i
can go bishop basics usually a decent
idea especially now after he has moved
in and now has to move again um night
takes I guess it's funny this position I
actually would have liked to have the
Queen's traded because that makes
playing d5 a lot easier hmm
not all that clear here what i should do
d fibers is is quite weakening 95 for
example can be an issue but it's hard to
play it without d5 a little bit
uncertain him now g 597
hmm might be okay yeah it's a it's a bit
shaky of course the center hmm I'm not
sure if I want to go d for here very
very loose position 9525 force my
intention let's do it but it's it's
really lose him jack ok it's not trading
hmm ok Queen a4 might be a reply to that
move so maybe maybe it would be eight
after all winning a temple ok well if we
go screen 84 I have Queen to d7 so ok
it's not doing this maybe I should have
taken actually ok yeah I just I just saw
that a little bit late
bit shaky as I said you threatened to
bring 28
and III is and isn't doing all that much
moves the rook but I can take a couple
of times right I can take 7 mm okay
let's get check the back rink stuff
even thinking about g5 here cutting his
his bishop off let's do it yeah that
wasn't ideal for white I'm okay now
definitely okay maybe I had something
better but I've spent lots of time in
the initial stages of this game and now
it it's a bit of a problem yeah then
that five doesn't do all that much not
sure about this move nachi for is the
thing it takes Knight takes Knight h6 I
think should be okay try and money just
that group which is six isn't that
dangerous
my g5 is also interesting check here
check now 2g to look f3 is also cool but
then Queen c4 is probably doing the
check
yeah I don't have a good move here it's
really crazy it looks like total crap
for white but I don't see a move I know
blood rage 7 I would a stupid game what
a stupid came as one of those way you
look afterwards computer show see how he
could have wonders so it's very very
Jackie that there was a winner check
even that isn't clear on eight seconds
but position is no I don't know rookie
seven now is he's got check and should
win problem
yeah go two seconds I what a shame now
Kim could have taken g5 him winning
check black for fits on time okay so Jim
it was kind of interesting it's this is
always difficult to assess do you have
enough compensation you're not i mean
i'm very active but check i don't think
it's objectively enough you should take
on have six it's quite clearly better
but ok so we had this and around here i
wasn't sure i thought that might be
enough I'm very center of Eric very well
centralize them then he allowed this is
g5 and now I'm winning it's just a
winning position h.323 so how do I
windows queen age five wins okay yeah
very easily actually because it's
threatening here and here so i will take
h3 and this is this is very easy okay
okay i played this and this isn't all
that clear even though this is right and
here you have to find some some way here
to do it i mean this isn't this isn't
enough it seems a bit of a miracle like
that there is no immediate kill him Oh
keV three
this is this is given by the comp where
the win head looks very good not only
window 0.6 going down it's pretty
awkward for white office levitt this is
somehow Jack didn't do the trick I mean
I didn't see a win and it seems there
isn't a clean one engine gives 97 which
is not very intuitive okay i blundered
age seven with with 20 seconds on the
clock jenkin the way you played it i
actually check could have taken g5 now
winning so there were tons of
possibilities to win this game but ok
bye now I had six seconds and he
probably didn't pay close attention went
here what just resins here if it's not
for having no second on the clock um but
I'd like to check the opening a little
bit sorry for screwing this up let's see
this is really a rare choice this
capture Bishop see form yeah Bishop a
six you can also play Bishop e7 maybe
this is the better choice actually to to
attack the pawn instead of playing
Bishop a6 here 94 looks pretty good yeah
I'm winging this pawn so it's so maybe
this is the better choice then yeah
that's probably better it covers that
then d5 maybe young very sharp stuff
okay so this is interesting but you know
one issue with this is always the the
weekend to light squares and this is I
didn't like and this also what I
what took me quite a while here in the
opening phase of the game check that it
was a little bit worried chair and this
is also clearly better than taking then
Bishop h6 this is the tricky situation
because he's got this one and currently
all my pieces are are not very well
coordinated this is a real problem here
not too shabby six here it's probably
quite okay also what the engine says it
gives this position as roughly equal
techno s to give in the in the Banco do
you have enough for the pawn or not
tough to judge very often ok guys thanks
for watching